something like uh push harry i mean are
they thinking about making some kind of
committal move going on the attack he's
going for it i mean i i thought he could
check and push harry definitely with a
knight but maybe he's aiming for
something similar with this move like
the f pawn or the h-pawn trying to try
and do something along those lines yeah
yeah so uh magnus after
over seven minutes wow brought his queen
to this square and uh simon says maybe
pushing this pawn forward maybe pushing
this pawn forward uh kind of keeping his
options open but he's also trying to
provoke sam forward so sam now it's very
tempting to push this pawn to hit the
white queen but the white queen might
even step back um i mean the whole way
anywhere safe and even if black starts
pushing white i think is happy to have
seen yes white's lost a lot of time but
white is happy to have seen this pawn
push forward because now at some point i
know black can try and attack i know
this is a bit scary but if black is just
a bit too slow and just waits for
example then after a trade of minor
pieces